it's been a week since the Eastern
Libyan city of Darna changed forever
the tsunami-like wave of water that
gushed down this Valley has left a deep
scar on the city its people and in the
hearts of the nation
those who survived the floods are trying
to process the sheer laws while
recovering what remains
still wondering if their loved ones are
alive or dead
thank God for giving us patience I'm
sitting in our area trying to clean it
and trying to verify who's missing I'm
trying to understand the current
situation I didn't leave
thousands are dead thousands more are
missing
dozens of local and international search
and rescue teams are working to recover
bodies from under the rubble or those
washed ashore into the muddy sea
authorities are still trying to
understand the scale of the destruction
the team assigned by the government to
take stock of the damages stated that
the total number of buildings in the
city is about
6142 of which the total number of
damaged buildings is 1500 891 buildings
were completely destroyed 211 were
partially destroyed and about 398 were
submerged in the mud the U.N migration
agency says more than 38 000 people have
been displaced in the east
and Libya's political situation with two
rival administrations has not made
things easy local authorities say they
are now working on a complete or partial
evacuation plan for the city of Darna
but with two governments the relief
effort has been chaotic and accurate
information hard to come by
people here say more needs to be done to
help those in need
we still do not know anything we are
hearing rumors some are trying to
reassure us others are saying you need
to leave the city we have no water and
no resources
damaged roads have made it difficult for
Aid to enter the city people are still
trying to come to terms with what
happened here those who remain in the
city are in desperate need of help they
hope it comes soon Malik trainer Al
Jazeera Tripoli
where families have started cleaning up
their homes after the floods in eastern
Libya but many people in vedna say they
will forever be haunted by the storm
I don't know what I'm feeling I can't
express it I saw death of my own eyes I
saw my family about to die in front of
my own eyes I wanted to hold on to
anything but I had nothing to say dear
God save my children and my husband
oh God I saw people dying in front of me
I saw death a moment that can't be
described as much as I'd like to
describe what I felt I can't express
what I feel
I still feel tired I can't rest I can't
relax a lifetime dream my husband and I
built up step by step I raised my
children happy that my son's wedding is
coming up it ended in a moment
thank God for everything